[Music]
hello everyone welcome to chess openings
explained i'm your instructor nick risco
and here we are with part two of our
scotch opening series tonight we're
going to be covering the scotch gambit
and at least the first i guess a major
part of the scotch gambit there's a lot
to it so we're going to break it up into
two sections tonight we're going to be
covering the london defense and uh
fourth move black plays bishop to c5
then next week we'll get into fourth
move knight f6 and then ackmanson
all right let's get right into it
all right starting with the london
defense so i'm just going to jump right
into it uh e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 and
d4 it's the scotch opening and we
covered this last week and all the third
moves that are not e takes d4
now
in most of those variations white's got
a very comfortable advantage very early
on and we found that black
is best off just to take on d4
and trade off these center pawns rather
than fighting to
uh retain the center central control
with the e5 pawn
so after e takes d4
the main line is knight takes d4 but
we're going to be looking at a very nice
alternative that white has
bishop to c4
and after bishop to c4 black has a
couple moves that they can try but i
believe there are
i think two three yeah three main
variations that we're going to look at
over this week and next week
the first one we're going to try
and take a crack at
is bishop to b4 check now when i was
doing my research for this there was
actually a lot of sources that were
claiming this is a very dubious move for
black one that a beginner might play and
might just completely you know white's
gonna run them
over right out of the opening but
when i was looking this
actually kind of seemed like it could
hold for black so let's take a look and
see what is happening here
the most common move for white and
arguably the best is pawn to c3 and this
pawn to c3 move is going to be one we're
seeing a lot tonight it is part of the
scotch gambit
and giving up this pawn for major piece
activity now black has no reason really
not to take
so they take and now after taking on c3
we're going to take with the pawn taking
with the knight is also fine um
in fact castling is fine here as well if
you castle here it's going to turn kind
of into like a danish gambit if they
take on b2
and takes on b2 with the bishop
and this is just i think a better danish
gambit
but tonight we're going to end up
looking at pawn takes as this is the
main move
and we're going to first start off with
this move bishop to e7 it might make a
lot of sense retreat the bishop get it
away from danger
um you don't want to put it back on f8
because then you didn't develop it so
why not e-7 that's actually the question
i'm going to ask the audience pause your
videos and try and find out why this
move is a mistake
all right
once you've unpaused your video the
answer is queen to these or sorry queen
d5
and the point is simply threatening
checkmate
now how does black actually defend
against this there's really only one
move and that's knight h6
but after knight h6 bishop takes h6 and
castles is the only way to defend f7
white retreats the bishop and white is
up a clean piece absolutely no
compensation for black and now white is
just going to develop the rest of their
pieces naturally with castles knight d2
really i don't need to explain this
position much further
so bishop e7 is a a big mistake
for black so
what do we actually do here
well first we're going to look at the
line bishop to c5 and i think this is a
an okay choice by black i think there's
better
but here
queen d5
does not work because after queen e7 the
queen defends both pieces so you don't
don't have a fork you don't have any
tactic here and in fact black is
slightly better white has not made a
concrete threat and now
d6 is going to come knight f6 is going
to come hitting the queen and the bishop
will get out to g4 so black's ready to
develop very quickly
instead white needs to change the move
order and go bishop f7 first and the
point is that if the king takes which
they should
queen to d5 check and now you are
forking the bishop and the king
now king to f8 is the best move here
getting the king out of danger
white is just going to capture on c5
the the most played move here is queen
to e7 you can try moving your other
knight but after castles i think white
is doing fine and black's gonna struggle
with their queen so black does offer the
queen trade
and
queen takes e7
not really the greatest move here um
this is going to look very similar to a
line we're going to look at in a little
bit but
there's a bit of a difference here here
white uh queen side pawns are a little
suspicious
and um just by trading off the queens
what gives up a lot of attacking
potential so here i'm going to recommend
just queen e3 keep the queens on the
board and
uh i guess the following sample line
knight to f6 knight to d2
and black breaks in the center with d5
putting pressure on e4 opening up the
bishop
white responds with e5 saving the pawn
but now
black has this really nice move knight
g4 and they are going to win this pawn
back
but first white's going to play a couple
moves to make it
at least a little bit more difficult for
black starting with queen f4
and while this doesn't save the pawn
here
the the point is that after king to g8
and castles when the knight captures on
e5 you can play rook to e1
and it makes it a little bit difficult
for black
black really has to play knight f3 and
then knight captures and after queen f7
this is a relatively balanced
balanced game here i i don't think
there's any
huge problems for either side black is
up a pawn but white does have a very
active knight
and i think this uh opposite-colored
bishops here the extra pawn won't make
too much of a difference
so
bishop to c5 does lead to a balanced
position here
but the line that i found which
i was talking with one of my friends
about this
who is also a
scotch gambit expert uh not really an
expert but he's a affectionato
um bishop to a5
and against bishop to a5
white normally castles to get out of the
way
and black has two main moves you have d6
and bishop to b6 so we're going to start
with d6 because i don't think this is
the most accurate move i think white
does get a very strong attack after
queen to b3
just hitting f7
queen e7 to defend
and now e5
after e5 i think
white does have the upper hand if the
pawn ends up capturing then bishop to a3
hitting the queen the queen goes to f6
and white gets all of his pieces
developed now after knight g to e7 which
is natural trying to castle king's side
there's knight e4
queen g6 and bishop takes e7 after
bishop takes e7 and king takes there is
uh queen a3 check
and now we have a problem if the king
goes to a light square it runs into
bishop b5 where you're getting ready to
capture on c6 remove the defender of a5
and if the king does something like go
to d8 then
either rook a or f to d1 is a lot of
trouble for black so
taken with the pawn definitely not the
way to go what black needs to make sure
to do after white plays e5 is to take
with the knight
and after taking with the knight there's
knight takes e5
and okay if the pawn takes this is going
to be a lot of trouble after queen two
b5
white is going up a piece there's
nothing black can do about it
so you do have to take with the queen on
e5
but after queen takes e5 white can snap
this pawn off the board with check
and at least secures an equal game
there are a lot of people who claim that
white is significantly better here even
winning but all the computers that i've
used stock fish 14
stock stockfish 11 all the way up to
depth 40
has shown triple zeros so
me personally as someone who doesn't
play the scotch that often uh i'm not
100 sure what to make of this but it
looks to be pretty balanced to me both
sides of three minor pieces white has
five pawns black has six but white is
showing a lead in development so i
believe this
this is an okay try for black
but i think there's even better than
this even better than this
is bishop to b6 now what is the point of
this
well
one of the main points is that this
bishop is now defended by multiple pawns
so moves like queen to b3 and then a3
like we saw in our previous line hitting
the bishop aren't going to be as strong
this bishop is no longer a target and is
an asset to black's position having
control of this long diagonal
and i had to try
to find something
against this move i can't just you know
allow this to exist and recommend lines
for the scotch gambits that don't work
so the best i could come up with
is pawn to e5 you start with pawn to e5
to limit the knight coming to f6 and you
also
kind of prevent this pawn from ever
moving forward at least immediately
because if it moves forward immediately
you can capture
and if the queen captures
you you could trade queens this is fine
you isolate the pawn and this is a
long-term target and can actually be hit
right away with a move like bishop f4
uh and in fact black really doesn't have
a great way to defend it and you can win
it back immediately
and black does have a better pawn
structure here
and the bishop pair so
black has that going for them but white
is almost completely done with
development and i think this is a try
um computers are giving away a slight
advantage but i don't want to be relying
on the computers too much me personally
i think black
practically could be a little better
um but okay i think the best try for
black here and probably the most natural
is knight g to e7 the knight can no
longer go to f6 because of the pawn but
you do want to castle so knight g to e7
is the move that i decided to treat as a
main line even though this position has
not really been played
and now we can see um a bit forceful
development from white starting with
bishop to a3
if the knight moves black can no longer
castle so black really should castle
immediately and again if d6 you can just
take it and now you already have the
bishop here to support
same for d5 if you just take on passant
so black
probably should castle here and now we
have rook to e1 supporting our pawn
not really looking to push it further
but we are supporting and developing
and now black has a couple moves here
starting with h6
it's a little unclear if pushing the d
pawn is good immediately allowing this
trade
um but you can delay developing this
bishop at least for the time being again
starting with
h6 and the point is stopping any knight
to g5 or
if the bishop was still on c1 it would
stop the bishop from going to g5
and now knight to a5 may be something of
concern to white with the bishop not
really having a great square to go to
other than d3
so we drop the bishop back to b3
and if knight a5 we can go bishop c2 and
now queen d3 to h7 is at least
a little trick white has here so i think
black should go rook to e8 um
immediately stopping a checkmate idea of
bishop c2 queen d3 because after queen
h7 king f8 queen h8 there's knight g8
so
um well actually in that position there
isn't because of the bishop on a3 but
uh these these are just ideas and that's
a lot of moves for white to be able to
pull that off black can definitely
respond in a timely fashion
um so after a rook to e8 it's giving the
king a little bit of breathing room
trying to contest this file white should
continue with knight b to d2
and here we see knight a5
um bishop to c2
could be played but now i think black is
going to be fine breaking open in the
center because white has blocked their
queen
so uh rather than bishop to c2 i think
we're okay giving up this bishop
knight takes b3 ab3 we fix our pawns a
little bit
and here knight to c6 was the best try i
could find for white in a couple hours
time
um
i think yeah this
i mean white has developments here
um all the pieces are very active you're
controlling your
really only weak pawn and black is
struggling to develop the light squared
bishop but now it's coming the time
where he has to push the d pawn and
develop so
while this is not this has never been
played before i do think that this could
be a very interesting try
for the london defense and definitely
should deserve some consideration
now i'm not the world's strongest player
so if i'm missing some refutation please
you know masters
experts even
come come show me why this doesn't work
but i think this is a
okay try for black
okay so that was really the only
sideline um
other than well no that was really the
only sideline
after our first few moves here after
bishop to c4 the other two main moves
are knight f6 and bishop to c5 now
as i mentioned earlier knight f6 we are
going to save this for our
lecture next week where we're also going
to cover the nakmansen gambit because
there is a transposition here
um where after castles knight takes and
knight c3 you do enter the nakmansen and
i'm just going to save it for uh for
next week so the rest of our lecture
here is going to be
bishop to c5
on move four and this is known as the
hacksaw gambit
and there's three different ways white
can continue here and i'm going to show
all three just to give some variety and
this is a scotch course i want to teach
as much about the scotch as i can
even if it's not a
repertoire based around one line
so bishop to c5 the first line we're
going to look at is a very aggressive
shot with knight to g5 this is starting
to give some fried liver
um kind of vibes here just attacking f7
and if knight to f6 you're just losing
on the spot after knight f7 forking the
queen and the rook
so black does have to respond to this
and the only way to really stop
capturing on f7 right away in a healthy
fashion
is knight to h6
the knight does move backwards it does
protect f7 this will stop an immediate
capture
now there's
two continuations here i think one is
much better than the other
we're gonna look at queen h5 first i've
seen this one going around and
some people recommending this for white
i do not think it is actually all that
great while it may work for some quick
tricks in blitz and bullet and classical
i think you're going to be wiped off the
board if your opponent knows this simple
refutation and it's not even like a um a
tactical refutation like you're going to
be losing material but
this move currently does not pose any
active threats other than saying hey i
have more pressure on f7
but because this move is so slow
black can actually just protect f7 with
the queen
and then after castles
um this also doesn't really give a huge
threat
and black can play knight e5 hitting the
bishop
and then once the bishop moves d6 and
the center
you can think whatever you want about
the center i think but um black is
catching up and actually surpassed white
in development they have both knights
and a bishop plus the queen developed
uh getting ready to castle
um
maybe even just castling on the queen
side to get out of this mess
whereas white only has two minor pieces
in the queen developed
so i think here
is
a little dangerous for white and engines
are giving this uh at least a minus 1.5
um
evaluation here uh with one of the main
threats currently being bishop to g4
trying to
attack and maybe even trap the queen the
queen does have h4 currently
but definitely annoying so something
like h3 for white and bishop d7 i don't
think black is facing any problems after
queen side castles
so uh that line with queen h5 known as
the vic's thumb attack
i don't think is all that hot
however
there there is a very popular
continuation here knight takes f7
and is kind of calling black's bluff
here of hey i don't think your knight is
really defending this position
and it's actually been worked out to a
equal position here after knight takes
f7
bishop takes f7 and the point is you
want to draw the king out
and follow up with queen h5 and this
does fork the king and the bishop and
white will regain their lost peace now
um
here
material is looking balanced there is a
very active queen
for the developed knight
and we'll go into some sample lines here
i believe the best continuation for
black here is to just play d5
and there's a couple tricks here if your
pawn ends up taking this is losing on
the spot to rookie 8 and your king
doesn't actually get to castle
if you play king f1 then b6 hitting the
queen
and while you would like to take this
knight this already enters a forced
mating sequence after bishop a6
c4 um
you can't uh take with the bishop
because of queen so you will take on
passant with the pawn it's also check
and then here you will
have to block with the queen
and after takes and king g1 it is met
with rook to e1
so this can lead to a lot of trouble for
white if they just take
if you're really greedy you might
consider capturing with the queen with
check
but we run into a slight issue where
after the queen trade you run into
knight b4 and black is threatening to
win material with knight c2
or simply capturing on d5
where
black is going to have this
you know 4 on 3.
i really
really don't see why
white should allow this going into a
possibly worse end game
so rather than either of those
masters have figured out castles is
perfectly fine and you allow black to
take on e4 now when i first saw this
position it was a little scary you know
both pawns
two center pawns white has zero center
pawns that's that's less center pawns
makes it seem like black can start to
roll these pawns down the board
but the continuation here with c3
um first looks scary because of d3 but
after something like bishop to
h6 i guess developing the bishop you you
also have um
what is it bishop g5 hitting the queen
defended by your own queen
as a move you should be fine catching up
in development
uh instead
one try i found for black is queen d6
looking to force this queen trade which
white wasn't so keen on just a second
ago even after getting the pawn
but here white really should take
there's there's no other fantastic
squares if you try checking on c4 it's
met by bishop e6 and while the king is
on f7
black has a lot of pieces developed now
so
uh takes pawn takes and now cd4 knight
d4
they're threatening knight to c2
rather than overreact with knight to a3
because you will end up losing your
bishop
due to some something like this
what you should do is just go knight c3
hit the pawn
and even though the knight does get to
c2
the rook has b1
in addition
white can actually get away with giving
up this rook so bishop to g4
knight takes e4
and after knight to c2 you completely
ignore this and you take on d6 so now
you're getting two pawns for the rook
and after
king to e6 and bishop f4 holding on to
your material
you'll get the two pawns and the
exchange
so here
what is it sorry um yeah white gave up a
pawn earlier so white's got a pawn and a
knight for a rook
and personally i would prefer black just
material insurance but aside from the
material white does physically have more
pieces
or not more pieces
hang on i'm tripping over my words
um white does have an extra pawn
that is an extra baby queen um and the
same amount of
pieces on the board
so
if if you're up for this challenge of
trying to win for white go right ahead
this line exists for you
but i think it's
it's pretty easy for black not to make
any huge mistakes
but this is um before bishop c5 five
knight g5 known as the sarat variation
okay
if white is not trying to be that
aggressive
which again i don't even think really
works out
um let's see bishop c4 here bishop c5
they can try this sideline of castles
now we're gonna get some
some hairy lines here and honestly for
the main line i don't even really know
what's going on
it's it's pretty chaos and with the lack
of games by strong players it's really
hard to figure out um a lot of what the
plans should be without trying to just
pour over engine analysis which could be
wrong
and also it doesn't really add much
productive value if you're just looking
at engines
so okay d6 d6 stabilizing your bishop
opening up your other bishop
and now you have c3 so again c3 offering
up the pawn to develop with tempo
black has two moves um both just
completely ignoring c3 i don't think
they should take because this is kind of
what white wants
but your two tries that black does have
is bishop to g4 and queen to f6 now
we're gonna look at queen to f6 this has
been played recently on the chess
between two 24 hundreds almost 25
hundreds
and i believe this does deserve a
mention
everyone
plays bishop to g5 super easy move to
find you're attacking the queen but
after oh not queen to f5 after queen to
g6 it's a little hard to see what white
got out of bishop to g5 right away
so i'm going to recommend a very
straightforward approach very direct and
allows you to develop easily
is b4 hitting the bishop the bishop has
nowhere to go about b6 and now a4
threatening to play a5 trapping the
bishop
uh really black's only moves are a6 and
a5
i'm gonna look at a5 engines seem to
prefer a5 over a6 after a6
um
white does have a5 anyway and after the
bishop goes back b5 trying to break
through
so
um i think better is just go a5
and now white has the decision of
pushing or capturing or even just
leaving it but
keeping up with this very direct
approach we're going to go b5 with the
pawn attack the knight
and if the knight retreats then white is
doing magnificent after e5
breaking open the position
you can even take on e5 with the knight
here because if the queen captures
there's rook e1
so
white just smashes through in the center
so really to stop this the knight should
go to e5
they are hitting the bishop they are
hitting the knight
so we are going to capture
d takes to prevent the pushing if the
queen takes then i guess this is fine c
takes d4 bishop d4 rook a3
um
but i think taking back with the pawn
undoubling the pawns is going to be most
people's natural choice
so
after d takes e5 what should white do to
continue developing we are going to get
rid of our backwards pawn on c3
and now bishop takes on d4 pawn can also
take but this does seem to lend itself
towards white after knight d2
uh there's just pretty easy development
queen f3
this bishop goes to b2
i think leaving the center closed is
going to benefit black
it also comes with tempo on the rook so
we just lift the rook to a3
and now black's most popular try is
developing the bishop to e6
and here you might be freaking out say
oh my bishop's attacked i need to defend
it but white has some
very strong moves here starting with
rook to f3 you insert this move first uh
if they capture on c4 you win a queen
although it should be mentioned it is a
queen for a bishop and a rook so it's
not like white is just completely
um crushing it but i would much prefer
to have the queen compared to
um
the the rook and what is it the bishop
so i'd much prefer to have white here
instead
after rook to f3 we see
two moves really
queen to e7 is probably the best move
but most people play queen to g6 and
when i say most people i'm talking about
players on chess.com and only chess
no master is going to allow themselves
to get into this position
but
okay
queen to g6
this is how two games have continued so
i believe it does deserve a mention
it is threatening bishop to g4
so the most direct response is rook to
g3 hitting the queen and rook to f6 now
if you want to draw my repetition here
go right ahead but i believe bishop to
g5 now is proper
and queen to g6
saving the queen
and now white has to be a little careful
not to mess up there are i believe two
games on the chess
and at least one of them
went bishop to h4 and lost to the game
and the reason this loses is because of
queen takes e4 first you're losing your
center pawn
and if you decide to take on e6
rather than take back
the capture on h4
now you save your bishop
and castles to protect the pawn
well now here i think black is doing
much better it's really hard to see
where the targets are
and black is caught up in development
they have an active queen active bishop
the knight is going to come either to f6
or e7
i i think this is doing just fine for
for black and white can't you know
can't really take um at least not here
because of the hanging bishop but if you
do something like queen f3
king b8 winning this pawn isn't going to
do you much um the position is still
rather closed
uh you can have fun with this but
um much better much much better
it's just bishop to e3
and the difference is that after queen
to e4
there's knight to d2 and would you look
at that there's no bishop hanging on h4
that the queen can take so the queen is
going to run in some trouble after queen
f5
now you take on e6 queen e6 and bishop
d4
and this is why it's better the bishop
hangs at the very end and they cannot
take because of rick e1
so
um yeah just white needs to be very
careful don't play
don't play bishop h4 here
make sure you play bishop to e3
and here because queen e4 does not work
queen f6 is really the best try
you can repeat
again like
uh white can can deviate with knight a3
but i'm just going to look at queen to
f6 immediately
where the best response here
again
staying very forceful now you do have to
worry about this bishop is queen to b3
and after takes takes and rook c8
protecting the pawn you just go knight
d2 you finish your development and after
knight e7 uh knight b3 hitting the
bishop and the pawn forcing it to go to
b6
and here i think white is doing just
fine there's many moves here to continue
bishop g5 um
sorry rook to f3 h4
all these are possible continuations but
i found this to be a very
forceful and rather clean way for white
to achieve
a decent position
so this is what happens if black goes
queen f6 here
after c3
now the most played move and the most
testing is bishop to g4
and the point of bishop to g4
is to kind of take and ruin your control
of the center and try and keep this pawn
and also
white's best way to continue the attack
with queen to b3
uh is
i guess neutralized a bit
bishop takes f3 now you do take on f7
first with chuck otherwise there's
really no point to queen b3
uh king 2f8
g takes f3 getting your material back
and now knight f6
and after knight f6
um we retreat the bishop back to c4 that
way we can move our queen later
and queenie 8 has been played here it's
also the the top choice and here bishop
to b5 pinning the knight
seems to be the best way but honestly
it's really hard for me to find
what exactly the plans are other than
black is going to try and uh
get the rook out maybe like h5 or h6 or
g6 queen g6
oops queen g6 is also
a very strong idea followed by i don't
know maybe knight h5
uh so there's definitely threats here
for black but i think white is a little
safe after king h1 and rip g1
and if you always need to uh i guess
rook d8 is a good move here
uh we're trying to find
what's actually been played
but okay like queen g6 king h1
queen h5 hitting f3 knight d2 white is
holding here
um but i
i can't really tell you much more
opening theory here other than just you
have to calculate and play your best
game of chess
um this is really getting out of the
opening and there aren't too many games
um
even that on leech us at you know 23
2200 level yeah you're not getting many
games above that
so
yeah i wish i could explain better
what's happening here but in this
sideline that nobody really plays um
kind of left without resources for you
but anyway this position here is
balanced there's a plan for black to
come and checkmate white is able to hold
if white can hold and develop their
pieces they're doing
fine but
i want to get to the very exciting stuff
the reason why you are turning on this
lecture and that is the true
scotch gambit
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 d4
takes and bishop c4
after bishop to c5
i believe the best trying move for white
is c3
[Music]
after c3
uh let's first take a look at what
happens if you decline there's less
theory here
and uh it's not as exciting we'll save
the exciting stuff for the end
but we do have knight f6 and after
knight f6 you should go e5 try and say
hey you put your knight on square i can
attack it move
now there is this idea of knight to e4
and bishop to d5 hitting the knight
and the point of knight e4 is actually
to sacrifice
white should accept and after
d takes c3
all the theoretical games here have
ended in draws
but
only one game has continued with
the best move king to g3 and this is why
i included this line
is uh the best move king g3 on move nine
how does it go from here well black can
take on b2 bishop takes b2
and this is starting to look like
everyone's favorite gambit the danish
gambit
and here black can castle
and there are many great continuations
for white but if you're ever worried
about this king being on g3 i believe
the safest is going to be h3 and if
black tries to come through with d6
you can take on c6 and after queen c2
um kind of developing
putting some pressure so they can't just
play d5
after bishop to e6 you can just tuck the
king away on h2 you can even
tuck the king away on h2
on the move prior
and white is doing fine
absolutely fine here um
a little bit of an advantage definitely
risky looking but i believe is very
solid for white so
94 nothing to really worry about you
just accept that sacrifice
after attacking it's really their only
idea
otherwise their knight is you know
trapped without really anywhere to go
but
the best move after
e5 is d5
and this is saying all right if you take
my knight i'm going to take your bishop
and i'm going to be better if f takes
then rook g8 and they're going to get
this pawn back and have a nice target on
g2
so
rather than accept trading off this good
bishop for this
decent knight
we just go bishop to b5
and now this is
transposed into the italian
which um
it looks like the classical
greco gambit but i will still continue
here
because there is theory we should cover
knight to e4
outposting the knight
c takes d4 re-controlling
our center here
and there's two moves here really
um bishop to b4 check is a try you just
block with your own bishop
and we've seen patterns here where the
knight does take on d2 if it does you
can just recapture with your b night and
you're catching back up in development
um but this line that i found for black
seems to be doing them just fine is just
ignoring
um that this bishop is on d2 and they
can capture you just leave this knight
on e4 because this is really nice night
um they just retreat the bishop back to
e7 so they don't get rid of the bishop
pair
and both sides castle
knight to c3 a6 hitting the bishop
bishop goes back to d3 after bishop f5
bishop e3
uh does give white a little bit of a
plus
you can take on c3 take on c3
and this is a balanced position got a
lot of center pawns together a nice pawn
chain
nice piece placement here on the king
side
uh but black is also you know solid
enough there there's no
no big problems in his position
so
um b4 is okay
there's also bishop to b6 and this is
the main line um followed by knight c3
looking to trade off
and black castle or sorry not castles
bishop to g4 uh i was seeing an engine
line here but bishop g4 is the most
played
um
you can go with
h3 h3 seems to be fine hitting the
bishop and once it retreats you go
bishop e3 you're over protecting your
center here because if they do take you
do lose a bit of control over d4
and now after both sides castle uh the
move seemed very natural enough it leads
both sides to a balanced position
and
this is really where i think most people
are going to go to
if they are declining taking on c3 so
the goodnight f6 this is what it's most
likely to transpose into
and i'll be honest there's probably
better resources out there for this
position this is a position from the
italian
but now we're going to get into the meat
of the lecture
and the very exciting capture on c3 this
is why people play
the uh the scotch gambit here is after
c3 and black takes
this is opening up an entire world
of possibilities for white
but they all start with bishop takes f7
king takes
if they don't take if they go king f8
then you can just take on c3 with the
knight and if they take here
you're going to continue with our
natural development that we'll cover
here in just a second
but really there's no problems here you
just develop the knights now and the
position is even better for white
so they really should take
allowing queen d5 check
and now we have a couple things going on
here first i should mention that if you
go king g6 it's made in one
if they try king f6
it is matan3 so bishop g5 king g6
queen f5 king h5 g4
this is mate
which really only leaves black with two
options
to f8 and king to e8
uh we're gonna look at king to e8 first
and hereafter king te8 what most people
play is just takes on c5 right away this
is completely fine you can do this this
is the go to move but it does look like
black is surviving and i will give the
sample line with queen e7
queen to e3
d5 knight takes i'm just going to scroll
through
pretty natural moves by both sides and
they're all the top engine
recommendation by stockfish 14 at depth
40.
so there is some confidence in here that
none of these moves are going to be
terrible mistakes
and if you run through an engine you'll
see at points white is plus one or two
um
i should note here the the special part
here is you can leave this bishop
hanging as there's no way for black to
add another defender so white does sneak
in some extra development but even using
these resources i find it very hard for
white to find a very huge edge and after
playing a bunch of moves we get to this
end game where it is bishop versus
knight and you have two different three
on twos
so
if you want to go for this again
completely fine um you can play this
against king to e8 but i found that
there's
probably
a little better
is inserting this check on h5 so queen
h5 check
does a couple things first if they play
g6 now you can take and they've weakened
their king side
if they don't they have two options they
can go king f8 and the point here is
that after king to f8 it transposes to
our main line after queen takes c5 so
we'll get into that in just a second
but
if they play king to e7 which is really
the only other alternative
um i found some really nice attacking
chances for white here
first you take on c5 and the difference
here between um capturing when the king
is on e8 is that this comes with check
so
there's
what is it two moves here
um but one of those really bad if they
go king e8 now and they're trying to
defend uh this way and they say actually
i do want my king on the back rank
uh white will achieve a very crushing
position very shortly just starting with
a very natural knight takes c3
no need to get into any
um queen checks you can just continue
naturally
um knight f6 and you'll just see white
is just always one move ahead black does
get d6 with tempo but queen c4 is always
fine
and
now that the queen we see the queen's
developed bishop g4 is no problem the
knight can just move and even after we
trade these pieces
and black gets to trying castle
after bishop to g5 trying to capture on
f6
this is a much better position for white
due to space due to activity um and this
king actually i think i misspoke um is
not able to castle at all because it
moved around so much in the beginning so
this king is just stuck in the center
and moves like e5 and rook to e1 are
just going to bring the attack right to
black
so okay
um king d8 is not a good move but you do
need to kind of know what to do just
natural developments
but d6 is probably the more aggressive
block you're blocking the track and
counter attacking and here you can take
on c3 with the queen
but nick you're you're blocking the
knights natural square well you're
you're making a threat that's going to
be my counter argument and forcing
knight to f6
and after knight to f6 you can castle
and black's best tries probably to go
rookie eight and try an artificial
artificially castle with uh bringing the
king back to g8 this way
but this runs into i think a very nice
continuation with this move b4
and this b4 idea i believe we're going
to see again later on but the entire
point of b4 is to destabilize the center
and i'm going to give a couple sample
lines here to demonstrate how that may
be the case
um bishop d7 was the first move i could
think of that seemed reasonable enough
is clearly not great for black the
queen's stuck
and it's not controlling anything else
and this is punished by playing b5
as soon as the knight goes back like to
b8
the center opens up with e5 and if
knight d5 you can move queen to d4
and you're attacking the knight there's
nowhere the knight can move with tempo
and you start to realize well okay if
knight to b6 trying to hold on
uh there's immediately bishop to g5
losing the queen
so uh knight to e5 is the move that
we're going to look at
and yes you should take the knight yes
black will take back
but no no no you should not get greedy
and take the pawn
by taking this pawn and allowing king to
f7 this actually accelerates black's
plan of wanting to castle artificially
and now it's actually coming with tempo
against your queen and black will be
winning the e pawn and soon you're going
to realize white's material advantage is
i guess not advantage but the material
situation is going to be equal and it's
actually going to be black who has
activity uh which neutralizes white's
counter play
so don't be greedy with taking on e5
with check
what you need to do is play this very
specific move f4
this works to open up the center open up
the lines for your f rook open up the
lines for your dark squared bishop
and black is practically in zigzag
there's no great move
the best that i could find uh is the
first try king to f8 um if the king ever
goes to the f file
f takes is going to win the knight
so
that is one tactical resource you have
so really they take on f4 and here after
bishop takes
i i couldn't find anything too great
um bishop takes b5 as the engine's top
choice and that just hangs a piece right
away
but the point is if something like king
to f7
well now bishop takes c7 hitting the
queen
and now you get e5
um i guess queen e7 now you get e5 it is
defended by the bishop and you are
winning this piece
so this is the point
just play f4
so okay we we clearly cannot allow white
to destabilize our center plate e5 or f4
and really rip open
rip open the lines so black really
should play a6 and stop this idea
white can try and play a4 and force it
through but after king fa to the king is
safe there is no e5 because this rook is
closed
so rather than a4
i think white or sorry
i do apologize
white
white should continue with a4
um trying to force it through getting
the king to f8
this is this is one line but i think
after a6 there's also just bishop to b2
um but bishop b2 looks to be much better
than a4
keeping the pressure up
and i decided to stop my analysis here
after knight d2
you bring your rooks to the c file and
the e file
and i think um even if you don't have a
crushing attack against the king all
your pieces are developed and black is
going to be working to just match your
space and activity
so
um
yes i believe
if
i think i lost my line here
do you apologize
aha
i see
um we are covering king to e8
i think i just messed up my notation but
okay
um yes queen h5 king e7 queen takes v6
queen takes here knight f6 castles rook
e8
uh okay okay i understand and the point
is that um after b4 here a6 um this is
the balanced position
um
but if they play something like bishop
d7 again b5 is going to win
um due to capture capture and f4
so this is what i found for rook to e8
now we're gonna get into what happens if
the king goes to f8 which is the main
line um i just accidentally switched my
lines around in the study which is why i
was confused
but okay um king to f8 is
um more often played i think
and this does allow the check
but d6 does come with tempo against the
queen and i'm going to
recommend something similar
i should also mention if the queen
blocks here
with the king on f8 i think this is
actually fine just to capture and you
capture on c3 with your knight and
we we saw a position like this earlier
and i said don't go for it but the
reason was because it was your pawn that
was on c3 instead of your knight but
with your knight on c3 i think this is
fine you go a6 to stop knight b5 bishop
e3 is developing d6 is developing your
bishop h3 is stopping any bishop g4
and after h6 stopping any knight or
bishop to g5
white is going to rest easy on his space
advantage and more active piece
placement
so
i think white is doing just fine here
but i will say d6
take on c3 with the queen you have
no threat on g7 this time unfortunately
and this is why
black should go to f8 in the first place
so it is going to be similar but not
quite the same because um
no threats here and the king not on e8
um the rook on e1 is not going to serve
as much of a purpose
so knight f6 knight 2 d2 and i should
note b4 is not effective here
because the king is not on the e file
it's not like if we get to play
b5
um
it's going to really work out for us and
black does have this immediate knight
takes e4 anyways
so
just knight to two
uh you are solidifying your center
and now king f7 trying to bring the rook
over
there is also queen to e7 here which is
a little bit of a mistake you can castle
and if black ever tries to take this
pawn it's not going to work out for them
because of rookie one and now white is
going to get way too much activity after
queen b4 and queen d3 queen d3 is a key
move here it's the only move that really
keeps a huge attacking advantage
um h6 just to try and create some
breathing room for the king
at any point
bishop d2 hitting the queen and now if
they're queen to c5
the knight
can go to h4 to g6 this can come up to
h4 maybe go to f4 this works coming to
c1
huge attacking place for white
at the cost of one pawn
so um queen e7
doesn't really quite work out if they
try and go knight takes e4 but it does
sort of work out in their favor with
bishop g4 but even here
um natural development is not going to
hurt white and again if what black ever
tries to capture this pawn in these
specific lines it doesn't quite work out
because of rookie 1 and b6
now there's knight g5 and the knight is
working
as an attacker as well and the queen
cannot take because of the bishop
so white will win the piece with rogue
takes e4 and eventually win the game
but okay after knight d2 king f7 this is
the only other try i could think of for
black where they try to castle
artificially
can continue with castle short
ripped to e8 putting pressure on the
pawn
and now now we can go b4
um there is no knight takes e4
due to knight takes rook takes and
knight g5
there is this fork at the end so this
this doesn't quite work
um and bishop d7 just ignoring it uh now
b5 does work again because the knight e5
rather than take on e5 which is still
fine because the king is on f7
there is this check and thanks to this
check there is a stronger alternative
there's king to g8 and now f4 misplacing
the knight and if knight f7
you take and after king takes there is
e5 and now you realize this knight is uh
slowly going to to uh be lost
if you decide to move the knight back
something like knight e4 a bunch of
captures on d6 already
and any capture on the file is just
devastating
so
there is this if bishop d7
so again we see that black must play a6
and now white can continue with bishop
to b2 and now this looks very similar to
our king on e8 to e7 line
um
what is the difference here
let me find it
do i really want to find it do i want to
risk messing it up
um
okay i can't seem to find it but uh
there are continuations here
queen to e7
uh developing the queen rook f to e1
king to g8 now black has castled
artificially one of the points of queen
e7 is to reinforce f6 and g7
and now rook a c1 and these are gonna be
the natural files for the rook
bishop to d7 and knight f1
and the knight is on its way to f5 and
h6 is
playable by black
um and while white is arguably better
black has survived there is a game that
is being played here
and i do want to make the note that
after knight f1 again this pawn is not
hanging because of rook takes e4 and if
queen takes it is mate so
you do lose a piece if knight e4
but this is the scotch gambit uh at
least the main ideas that i could find
if i ended up missing anything i do
apologize and i can try to address it in
our next video
um or in the comments section below um
i'm sure i'm going to be having a few
questions here but um these are the best
tries that i could find for white
um and again i think uh
a lot of these lines do deserve some
more attention you might seem a lot at
the club level unfortunately not at the
master level i think they're a little
too dubious
um but yeah that's it let me know if
there's any questions drop them down in
the comments below and we will see you
next week with uh knight f6 and
enactments and have a good night